good morning millennials
welcome back to the toast happy Tuesday
nope Wednesday Wednesday happy Wednesday
we are putting the family in friends and
family week here at the toast because
I'm joined by my little sister my coffee
doll my inspiration and kind of also my
muse that's true it's the snatchler hi
everyone welcome oh my God I feel like I
haven't been here in a while you haven't
been to this studio in a very long time
yeah I mean the last time I I did this
was here but I don't even remember when
that was probably maternity leave yeah
or when I did QVC from the studio yes
um so I'm excited to have you here this
counts I have a lot of stories some I
know you're super well versed and like I
want to talk about Taylor's breakup
because Jackie and I spoke about it on
Monday but you know it's different
energy 100 talking about Taylor Swift
with toxic Jackie so I want to talk
about it with you yeah yeah and we're
going to talk about Tom Sandoval okay
and we're gonna talk about a lot but I
kind of wanted to get the exclusive okay
on what's going on with the counts
before we dive we also have deer
toasters today
um but before that like let's talk
because snitch on the toast snitch on
the toast
snitch on the toast um I'm good no I'm
not done with myself I'm so sorry and
that jingle reminds me of it's best of
both but um it's best of both rip so for
those of you who are new here Margo has
had a podcast on toast News Network for
quite some time they recently went
through a Rebrand and then you recently
just kind of dropped an episode being
like listen this podcast life is not for
us yeah we're out she hosted it with her
best friend Nicole who's in law school
um talk about it yeah I mean I think it
was something that like we both
struggled with like we kept doing it
because we were just like we have to
sort of thing like it's like we it was
like a part of us but then I think there
was one point and I spoke to you guys
about it I was just like it's just like
it's not working it wasn't working like
I have so much going on like I have a
corporate job I just got promoted like I
got I got like a big job and Nicole's in
law school like she's about to start
studying for the bar like no one wants
to hear about like how she's just like
holed up in her apartment right and it's
just like it there it just wasn't
working and you know what like I think I
actually like naturally one of those
people I think it's so important to like
know when something's not working and to
be able to be like it's bye no it's
totally fine to like acknowledge that
like you're not enjoying it yeah it's
not working like I don't think you were
putting out like your best episodes I
think your best episodes maybe were
behind you 100 and it wasn't making
either of you guys happy so like move on
exactly
um but like a lot of people you know
conspiracy theory like there's other
things going on but like no you and
Nicole are good are people conspiracy I
might I must not be in those I think
they are it's just like you know you
just kind of just felt random for you to
like drink yes but it felt like behind
the scenes like it was it wasn't yeah um
but yeah but also like how do you not
make that random like do you want us to
say every episode like we hate this like
hey this is gonna come to an end soon
yeah that's rather just like live in la
la land rip off the bed then rip off the
Band-Aid but you and Nicole are good
yeah we're good everything yesterday
everything's good everything is good
there's no drama well toast News Network
actually hasn't been the same but the
good thing is is that if you're looking
for bits and pieces of this natural you
can still find her on the redheads book
club podcast which meets once a month
I'm still a podcaster yeah I can handle
the once a month life I know I know so
this works like you're so busy like it's
just what's going on in your life
um work is good like I said I just got
promoted so wait did you get promoted
yeah I did
have you ever been devoted
there's a follow-up have I ever been
promoted no but I just want to say it's
not because like I wasn't no of course I
just have been doing this always no for
sure the reason I asked was like you
don't know the feeling of like when like
it's the best feeling ever you're giving
like corporate judgment energy
it's just such a good feeling no no
we're really proud of you and we're
happy for you so that's really great
we're promoted to what a director to
president no not yet president of this
company I'm the owner of this house I'm
the owner of this house oh no not yet
not even [__] close but okay she's a
director it's her directorial debut it's
my directorial debut love that for you
um but besides that everything is good
in my life knock on wood like wood knock
wood
um I am still single guys don't worry
but actively working on not being right
um relatable no PA stories though for
you this time yeah that was a good one
you call me at a good time other days
have been on I've been pretty good
really yeah that's such a relief you
know these these guys Margo yeah and we
get a lot of and so it's good for deer
toasters today because I feel like you
can relate we get so many submissions
about like just guys doing the most like
abhorrent things not it's not like you
know so outright like he pushed me it's
like say and doing the most like
disgusting weird they also do like the
absolute bare minimum and think that you
need to like give them a round of
applause right and like a [__] yeah
no like it's not happening no I feel for
for the single girlies out there like I
obviously love Ben and I'm grateful to
him but I'm also grateful to him like
that I don't have to do that yeah but
also like I will say I mean it depends
like how you are in nursing illness like
some people are like so upset that
they're single some people embrace it
yeah so it depends but like the thought
like of like that someday probably like
soon in the near future like God
willingly yeah I'm like gonna have to
like share my life sounds horrendous
yeah well not share your life because
that part is actually great it's the
share your space like it's just like all
of it like it's no longer just like me
and Max like you have to be me Max in
this other person aren't you looking
forward to a father figure in Max's life
she needs that kind of stability she's
kind of like this recluse like she's
just like she comes with a broken family
and she needs like a strong paternal
figure no like
I think that she like we have such a
good thing going you do but like Max
loves everyone and so imagine there's
like another warm lap for her to lay in
that for sure that that I'm excited for
but then it's also like get the [__]
away from my dog let me ask you
something Margaret it's gonna be our dog
just you have to be yeah let me ask you
something like let's say you started
seeing a guy and it was like going
really well and you were really happy
and like into him and then he like comes
over and either he's like allergic to
dogs
or like he just doesn't like connect
with Magnolia the not connecting part I
don't mind because that can be worked on
and like will eventually be rectified
and whatever more for me but the
allergic part not an option because it's
on my hinge it's on your she's on my
hinge like what do you put on hinge like
it says pets yes pets yes and then one
of my photos is me Max of course because
literally the most important person in
your life has to be acknowledged
obviously and am I understand like a
picture you are we have one family photo
the one from Utah oh so it's like an old
ugly picture okay I look gorgeous
yeah okay oh actually you and I are
doing like an upcoming brand partnership
together and last night they emailed
asking if there's a photo that we both
approve uh we're gonna have to photoshop
so I said we would take one today like
let's take a gorgeous photo today but I
don't have like my hair done and
shouldn't a gorgeous photo be like us in
like dresses
we're gonna have to talk about it we'll
Workshop it the thing is like I can
really only work with photos taken in
the last like three months
but can we Photoshop a photo together
okay I knew this is gonna be a problem
okay we'll we'll have to figure it out
like
maybe we just send separate photos I
agree but that really wasn't like can
they just pull from our Instagrams those
are clearly approved those are approved
but like like I said only from the last
three months okay
okay so all is good with counts like
all's good with counts feeling good we
have so much fun good stuff coming up I
know we finally got our tickets for the
first show to Taylor in Nashville I was
updating everyone on the podcast about
it
you [__] [__] I literally did the
next day I was like first of all do you
know what I'm gonna die no tell me what
why don't you
you [__] please just tell me no I
listened that day the one time I did the
first day I talked about it like I was
just kind of telling the story of what
happened and you it was very like me me
like I I yes I agree because I I did
everything the next day you then really
took on the Reigns but you listened to
the podcast from the day before the next
day it's like so much had happened then
the next day which I know you didn't
[__] listen to because you don't
support women in podcasting I said oh my
God and Margo's been doing so much so
the spreadsheet I give you so much
credit okay thank you but you just
weren't there to listen you just want to
complain you just want to complain I
learned that from you you just got a
good thing
so we got our tickets for Nashville eras
we also just got tickets for New York
eras but right it's gonna be we're gonna
go twice to New York because there's
three shows we can also like we're going
with a brand that was so clutch so
clutch and they have a suite so that's
another suite for us which is great but
we need to experience eras from like
with the people yeah and we need to feel
the energy also like it's important to
note that we might have to go to all
three because if there's one chance at
one of them at life surprise songs is
Long Live and we miss it I'm just
letting you know you're never gonna see
me again okay why would you think it
would be long live like at MetLife well
I don't I'm just saying like the if she
hasn't performed long live at any point
like it gets closer and closer unless
like Long Live it's gonna be like the
last one but Mario in her rotation of oh
my God calm down and you said Margo like
weird in her rotation of surprise song
she has not been throwing in speak now
songs has she
it's been red it's been Evermore it's
been that's a fair point but I get like
there's in no world I know could she not
perform the one song she has about her
fans it's literally the soundtrack of
the era store it makes no money it makes
sense she's just open with it like yeah
it makes no [__] sense so
that's all yeah that was all I'd say but
also Stagecoach what is your dream
lineup for surprise songs
Long Live obviously oh and then I
haven't really thought about my second
one
um I think
I'm not gonna assume it would be a speak
now as well but maybe oh new Romantics
duh yeah new Romantics is good there's a
few for me like and I kind of feel like
I might get maybe not at my show but I
think she might do at some show this
song because she's not been choosing
like fan favorites she's been choosing
songs that have like weird cult
followings you know yeah like Tick Tock
right and for me that's peace like if I
feel like I could get peace somewhere I
think that especially now you should be
getting peace I just want to like warn
everyone who's in a 10 mile radius and
be like she [__] sings peace like I
will I will not be okay yeah I will
vomit on the floor okay and then eat it
up and vomit it up again okay I think of
peace I think of you like
in smoking pot no no I think of you with
your coloring book yeah in like a puffer
sitting in like 20 degree weather
looking at nature yeah that song is
really important to me no I know so new
Romantics same I also would like kind of
love if she did you are in love oh my
God the ACT oh my God yeah I realized I
guess I didn't realize she didn't do it
I've only had like a recent appreciation
for that song we saw 1989 on tour and
like I think maybe that was my bathroom
song like I wasn't really and I just I
was wrong which happens to me literally
all the time oh my God it's so true I
was so wrong so I would love that and
also I would love to hear clean but she
just she did it yeah ten months old I'm
trying to think of like I feel like she
really like covers lover oh death by
Thousand Cuts she did it
did she just with clean that show got
clean and death by a Thousand Cuts just
this weekend in Chicago those are the
luckiest people no it's so unfair that
yeah she really should do one shitty
surprise song and one good surprise song
at the same time or maybe two good ones
like how about that Taylor well she did
two good ones but I'm saying it's not
fair for everyone oh yeah for everyone
yeah yeah yeah so okay we have a lot of
Taylor news because let's just get into
it I think it's time I have my iPad is
like chock full of tabs today I got
stories I got to your toaster so without
further Ado you want to do it no I don't
feel confident enough because you don't
listen to the show and you don't know
how we do it anymore no I I saw the one
with you in bed and you guys go wow no
you fight for it no we don't yes you do
you fought for who does the who was
fastest no lie I saw it no it was on
Tick Tock we don't do that because we
only did it when Ben was here because
Ben is hasn't approved the change but
Ben knows the chain oh so you don't know
I don't know so you say hi I'm Margaret
hi I'm Margo Australia and I don't
support women in podcasts I didn't know
where that was going I'm not saying that
all right without further Ado
here are the fast side stories that you
need to know
that's it oh my God what a change it's
it it really shook that you know it's so
interesting because I was actually
thinking about when I saw the thing of
Ben I was like what do they say because
you wouldn't say like morning toast
anymore so I was wondering and now I
know and it's almost like you could just
call me and ask I know I like I have I
think of things and then I just like
live in Wonder oh man that's so my life
like these pants that I'm currently
wearing today that I'm obsessed with
they're from Lululemon I put them in the
wash three days ago and I kept
forgetting to put them in the dryer and
then they get smelly when they sit in
the wash yeah so you have to re-wash
them of course and as I'm falling asleep
last night I'm like oh my God I never
put them in the dryer but I really
wanted to wear them today so I did get
up like I was about to hit REM yeah I
mean but I did it my the number one
thing that I think one of my issues is
is that I remember things and I'm always
like you should write this down because
you're gonna forget and I always always
forget like my number one feedback from
my boss in my review was like I tell you
to do things and you go and sit back
down at your desk and you don't remember
you need to leave a pen and paper on
your nightstand or not even just at my
phone like no phone is not like writing
it down it you will remember it like the
10 about the hand motion you will
remember I know uh every time I pick up
a pen and paper which is like maybe once
a year I like can't write yeah same do
you write a lot in your job
um honestly no when sometimes I'll make
my to-do lists like you can't write it
just because I think it's like better
and easier to remember but even like
this past Sunday I was doing like some
spring cleaning uh yeah so I went to
Margaret's apartment recently for the
first time in a while and I could not
believe what I just like have so much
[__] so I
was like you know how before you go to
bed sometimes you're like I haven't seen
like this item in like a while that's
the [__] word and so then you get up
and you find it
so I I have this one thing where like
this happens I this happens a lot
because it's like it's a very nice item
but I never wear it so it's like knowing
that I have it but like it's not like a
constant so I'm like I just need to know
where it is at all times so I'm going
through like my
Bureau whatever and I'm going through
everything and I've realized I've gone
through everything and I'm like I
haven't seen her and I like don't know
where she is so I I called Claudia I was
like oh no you call me just like talk
about something and I was like I'm so
sorry I literally can't focus on this
conversation probably talking about
myself and I couldn't find it and I was
like going back and forth going back and
forth knowing that I had one of these
things where I couldn't find something
before I went to sleep and I was like
okay let me like be smart and put in
like a smart place and hit it from
yourself I hit it for myself and I knew
like when I was going through everything
I was like I know that I put it
somewhere and I knew that I wrote it
down yeah and I don't I could not find
it so I think actually I don't know if
writing it down helps because where do I
then put that thing you know I feel like
in every young woman I did find it by
the way she did find it and she was so
happy I feel like in every young woman's
life and I feel like every person can
relate to this there's like something
most likely a piece of jewelry that they
lost in like in their life I mean that
haunts them yeah what's yours the
earring two pairs of diamond earrings
yeah
that wasn't even what I was looking for
because I I will never get I will never
get a pair of diamond earrings ever
again
never if anyone who will date me at some
some point in my life never forget his
hair it's a curse yeah the first time
you were like a lifeguard right and you
think it fell off in the pool um no the
first time I think I just like lost it
and like that was bad and like that was
totally on me yeah the second time it
was not on me I was wearing them and I
was training to be a lifeguard for my
like summer job and we had to like do a
dive yeah to like go save someone so I
dove and it came out of my ear and you
felt it I felt it it was an
Olympic-sized fool and I was at the
bottom of that [__] pool for hours
looking for the diamond earring
obviously I didn't find it it's tiny
probably went down the drain yeah
um oh that story like that was tough
haunts me I think for me and feel free
to drop in the comments what's your
trauma loss of like an item you'll never
saw again but that weirdly meant a lot
to you you know growing up we all had
those name plates Jackie still has hers
it says you still have yours yes I don't
have mine I don't know I it's not even
like oh I I was biking and I lost it
like it just got lost in time and I'm
really upset about it yeah that's an
upsetting one but I should just get one
made will you send me a picture of yours
like okay I like I saw it the way that I
know that I have this because I saw it
this weekend and it was like a gift from
yeah
Olivia still has hers too
probably well I feel like Olivia has a
different one because she's a silver
girl I feel like I can like an imagine
yeah that was tough okay sorry we
totally went on Nintendo yeah
but that you need to know period today's
episode is brought to you by neutralfall
30 million women are impacted by
weakening weakening or thinning hair if
you're among them no you're not alone
and there's a solution you can trust to
deliver results millions of Americans
are experiencing thinning hair and you
know what recently that's been me I was
telling literally you last night I have
obviously experienced like a change in
diet and a very sad effect of that is I
will like run my fingers through my hair
and this happened like a few months ago
where I started noticing where I would
curl my hair and in my lap I could make
a wig I was like that's like a lot of
hair to lose and of course you lose a
little bit of hair every day but it
really started to freak me out where I'd
run through my hair and like see kind of
chunks coming out
um and Jackie and a lot of my friends
have used neutralfall and I felt like it
was like a really trusted brand and I've
had a really good experience with it it
is a number one dermatologist
recommended hair growth supplement it's
clinically shown to improve your hair
growth the thickness and the visible
scalp coverage nutrifall supports
healthy hair growth from within by
targeting the five root causes of
thinning which can be stress hormone
environment nutrition and Metabolism
they have three unique formulas to
support women through all stages of life
including postpartum and menopause each
formula is physician formulated using
natural drug-free medical grade
ingredients and consistently effective
dosages so you get the most reliable
results so you can grow thicker
healthier hair and of course support the
toast by going to nutrifold.com and
enter promo code toast you'll save ten
dollars off your first month
subscription this offer is only
available to us customers for a limited
time plus free shipping on every order
get 10 off at neutriful spelled
n-u-t-r-a-f-o-l.com promo code toast
today's episode is also brought to you
by Athena club and you know what I've
been like rocking shiny shaved legs
because I recently got a new razor and
the holder that like it attaches to the
wall with and you know what I kind of
feel like I'm not like other girls like
I shave my legs in the wintertime [__]
like I'm not like you wow so Athena
club's razor has over five thousand star
five star reviews from customers and it
is designed with built-in skin guards to
help prevent razor burn while being
gentle on curves the razor blade is
surrounded by a water activated Serum
with shea butter and hyaluronic acid
which of course as we all know is a holy
grail for skin care the best part of the
razor kit is that it's only ten dollars
and it comes with two blade heads a
magnetic hook for shower storage and
your choice of handle color
um so me and men like had this really
dark period where we were shaving a
raise sharing a razor oh and I just felt
like considering like what I shave and
like when you shave like I just feel
like it's not cool and so I got myself
like a whole new setup from Athena club
I'm like Ben [__] off I got a pink one
and I hung it on my side of the shower
we have two different sets of shelves
like this is clearly mine and I'm
telling you I know he's still using my
Razor like who wouldn't it's so gorgeous
and like every time I go it's probably
like from Duane Reade yeah I like pick
it up and I look and I'm like I just I
could tell you know that he's been using
it it's really annoying
um they also have the best shave foam to
use while you're are shaving and it will
leave your skin soft hydrated and smooth
share your skin you care with the Athena
Club razor kit head to athenaclub.com
and use code toast for 25 off your first
order again that's athenaclub.com use
code toast for 25 off Athena Club has
also launched in Target stores
nationwide so make sure to check out the
Shaving aisle to buy their products in
store IRL all right Margo our first
story is something I know you did your
homework on last night so I really
appreciate yeah and I know you know the
basics and I actually feel like you kind
of knowing the bare minimum and me
knowing everything is perfect for the
story that I'm about to share so Andy
Cohen has dragged Howie Mandel's
interview with Tom Sandoval saying he
didn't do his homework so the watch
weapons Live host laughed at Howie
Mandel's interview with Tom Sandoval on
Tuesday night's show claiming that the
podcast host didn't do his work so you
know Andy ends his show doing a muzzle
of the day right and Jack hole of the
day and he named his Jack hole Howie
Mandel for like having Tom Sandoval on
his podcast and like literally this is
the interview of a lifetime I I'm just
confused by like who like why they chose
that okay let me tell you I don't even
need my iPad look I know more than this
about paychecks so weirdly okay so you
know Tom Sandoval and he's like he's
turned 40 and he's been having a midlife
crisis and like a few years ago clearly
a few years ago he started like this
band it's I've seen it on Tick Tock Tom
Sandoval and the most extras
because literally one time three years
ago on the show somebody called him
extra and he tried to like turn it
around and like make it when people like
do that no you can do it like Taylor did
smart Taylor did it with like snakes and
reputation like yeah you did it with
disgraced Queen we did it with disgrace
Queen this is not the same so it was
just cringe and it's like a cover band
and it's for literally 15 people in the
band it's the biggest thing no okay and
it's just like narcissism in its truest
form like yeah yeah so one of the guys
in his band who he literally pays his
band members a thousand dollars a day
like just to hang out with him like the
band is bleeding money it's crazy one of
his band mates is just like a you know
he's a part-time musician part-time
comedian and he does uh podcast
production for Howie Mandel uh so it's
just this weird coincidence and from
Howie's perspective I mean who knew
Howie Mandel had a podcast this was a by
the way I had no idea it was a great
thing for Howie and I'm glad he had the
uh self-awareness to bring his daughter
in I don't know if she sits in on every
podcast I don't think so so
at its core like okay I can understand
for Tom Sandoval I mean he's such a
[__] thirsty [__] narcissist
for him to be like I mean he could go on
any show right now yeah like we would
have him you know yeah he's probably
like afraid
for him to go on the show of a person
who has quite literally no idea what's
going on the stakes are so much lower it
was actually kind of smart like I
understood it how he's not going to
check him and be like but on August 24th
this Bravo account reported he's not
gonna get checked so you know what I
kind of understood it
I said don't watch it I had to watch it
three separate times I watched the first
10 minutes when it first came out and
Margot it was so mind loving an hour and
20 minutes oh my God it was so
mind-numbingly stupid I I said you know
what this is gonna be my 13th reason I
can't watch this then last night before
bed I was like Margo's coming on the
toast it's not like you know I can let
Jackie watch it right I have to watch
this whole thing so then I watched the
next 40 minutes and I was like you know
what I can't keep going like I can't
keep going I feel as though I've gotten
the gist yeah and then this morning when
I was getting ready I was like you know
let me just put it on the background and
I finished it and you know I didn't
really you really didn't need to watch
any of it I had seen like some tweets
recapping it and it was enough
it was so crazy Margot so first of all
Howie Mandel has no [__] idea who
these people are they're his daughter
and Tom are like going back and forth
about castmates and he's just chiming in
who's Sheena shut up oh that's so
annoying to ask to interrupt the
conversation with like basic
clarifications that's like literally
I can't even think of a comparison
that's too bad it was so infuriating so
basically the roles I think were meant
to be like how we good cop daughter bad
cop okay because Howie is very much like
an advocate for mental health and Tom
has gotten you know the fans have turned
on him and he's been in a really dark
place so I think Howie was meant to take
the place of like you know we're human
we all make mistakes you cheated on your
partner you know you're not a murderer
um and his daughter was supposed to like
kind of poke inconsistencies in his
story he was just lying about the whole
timeline and everything and she just sat
there she just sat there and you know
what I don't think Howie Mandel was
really prepared for what would descend
upon his podcast you have to read the
comments Margo his daughter's Instagram
like Bravo fans are probably the most
fanatic of any any network for sure
totally I would say it's on par with
like uh like a pop stars fandom BTS like
they're really they don't let [__] go
and they just they don't forget a thing
Margo I went to the daughter's Instagram
I actually felt bad for her they were
breaking her like it was on her to to
represent them yeah and to just so the
whole interview
and how he was like listening to Tom's
side of the story and Tom is this like
crazy Tom is a legend in his own mind he
thinks he is the hottest most greatest
most talented man on Earth and so he's
telling his side of the story which is
basically you know he just he fell in
love with someone else so they're in
love are they still together he didn't
want to put labels on it right now but
yeah
um he fell in love with someone else and
he was in this relationship with someone
who you know
was depressed like she's been very open
about her she said like bouts of
depression and so it's like Howie you're
over here being like mental health
Advocate and you're he's like literally
making fun of Ariana he's like she
didn't want to leave the house I'm like
because she's depressed yeah because she
doesn't like you like he was just being
he was being horrible to her and the
whole time they left out the most key
part of this affair and like the
Dynamics of all these three people is
I didn't just fall in love with some
girl right he fell in love with Ariana's
best friend like Raquel has been brought
into this group brought into the show
like she could have she was brought in
because she was in a relationship with
James and when they broke up like
everybody could have like ditched her
and not filmed with her and she wouldn't
Ariana like made sure that the girls and
then Sheena started becoming friends
there it was all Ariana Ariana's a
really nice girl she's never been like
the starter of the drama
and they totally freaking fluff that out
that's like such an important piece of
content why it's so [__] up that's why
it's right I mean it's [__] up period
but right but like another level Margo
this interview it was infuriating and
the whole thing about Tom and Ariana and
they really weren't never a match
because Ariana said from the beginning
she's very you know
anti-patriarchy she's very not
traditional she doesn't want to have
kids and she doesn't want to get married
she likes being in a relationship she
doesn't feel the need to get married and
Thomas never like fully been on board
with those things and those are core
things if you met someone who didn't
want to have kids like yeah that's a
deal breaker right there's certain
things that are just
for some people deal breakers
and he said towards the end of the
relationship like he was really
withdrawn because he had fallen in love
with Raquel she didn't know that and he
had suggested they go to therapy and
therapy really started working for
for Ariana but he had to take taken her
therapy to break up with her in therapy
but she started using the therapy as
like oh my God like let's fix this
and she wanted to have a conversation
with him about freezing her eggs like
for him it was so hard to say that yes I
couldn't believe he was admitting all
these things because he probably doesn't
even realize that it's like wrong
narcissist yeah he was saying these
things that were so heartbreaking that I
think he was saying to defend himself
but made him look so bad he also said
you know there had been like rumors and
like people saying certain things about
me and Raquel but Ariana didn't believe
it she chose to trust me
that's what because you should literally
how bad does that make you look now some
of my inside sources it was very odd
because
the cast has been doing their own pod
Sheena has a podcast
um Lala has a podcast they all a podcast
so they've been blowing this up in part
because it's their job you know there's
a big scandal going on in their show
their show is being is so relevant right
now it really hasn't been relevant in
many years right so they're all making
the most of it and they're all defending
Ariana and I think everything they're
doing has been done with Ariana's
blessing you know Lala selling merch
about you know with something about the
Scandal on it and it's all going to
Ariana's favorite charity like oh Ariana
is very much a part of all the girls
they're really close with her and Tom
was going on and on about how disgusting
it is that they're all exploiting this
and like Marco if you only knew how his
role on the last eight years of the show
has been finding other people's like tea
and skeletons and bringing it to light
like he's the bone carrier to hear him
be like it's just so disgusting like
I've known these people and they're out
here exploiting like
pot Kettle your [__] black
Margo it's
as somebody who knows the history to
watch the interview was an exercise in
self-control like just okay I have two
questions yeah does Andy Cohen hate Tom
Sandoval so I mean I don't know if
Andy's like getting personally invested
in the drama I think he's so grateful as
he's like an executive he really was one
of the first champions of the show right
I think he's grateful that this is
happening I'm sure at the reunion he
never takes sides but he does push he
asks the obvious questions he's a very
good a few times he's dropped the ball
in Bravo history Bravo uh Monique
Candace but for the most part he like
asks the questions and he scours the
internet for like Bravo fans and he
takes their questions so Andy doesn't
like hate him but he's definitely not
gonna help him in this situation
Schwartz
it's a very good question Margo I'm glad
you you're a very good student Schwartz
is a very interesting because and that's
what he kept saying Tom Sandoval in the
interview he's like I don't know why
everyone's getting about there's three
people in this me Ariana and Raquel and
like that's really not true one because
he told Schwartz and like Schwartz knew
about it and Schwartz is friends with
all these people he put Schwartz in the
worst position I've ever told him and
Schwartz has been like doing interviews
and he had to go and watch Robin's live
and he like can't keep his timeline
straight he like doesn't know what he's
supposed to say and he's really not that
smart like it's it was actually painful
his interview on watch Happens Live
um and you know Schwartz has rid so hard
for Sandoval forever it was a huge
reason why he got divorced Tom Sandoval
was so mean to Katie Maloney Tom
Schwartz's wife and Tom Sandoval I mean
Tom Schwartz excuse me like never
defended his wife and then that was just
a pattern in their relationship but it
was really bad with Tom Sandoval so to
say that Tom Sandoval was a reason for
their divorce is entirely accurate I
know it sounds crazy but like it was
fair but Schwartz just like [__]
rides for this guy so hard and nobody
knows why that's weird like they're
business partners that I get why you
would want to keep a good relationship
but to Time After Time people are hating
Tom Schwartz now for his part in this
right is it worth it this friendship
doesn't sound like it you lost your wife
yep their businesses are [__]
inflamed nobody wants to support Tom you
know Bravo fans they they know their
support is like
you know wield that like a weapon yeah
we'll come to shorts and Sandy's or we
won't yeah
so there was one more point I wanted to
make oh and I did here and I it was
fairly obvious you know because a lot of
people have been like Ariana should do
an interview
before this Tom Sandoval interview came
out and I think a lot of people thought
the natural place for that would be call
her daddy and Alex Cooper even posted
something being like I see you
Bravo at PR will not let anyone do an
interview until after the reunion airs
the reunion airs at the end of May so
Alex was like honestly I don't know if
it'll like still be relevant relevant
and I would love to do it now but it's
just not gonna work out she told
everyone just like back off like I'm
trying but but this
and so Tom went ahead and did this
interview without approval from Bravo
without approval from PR without
approved from anyone so he's like making
enemies everywhere he goes he's so dumb
he's so dumb especially because his
contract is up and he
either can or cannot resign for this
upcoming season I mean I don't know what
he could do that would make Bravo fire
him this is he has to be on the next
season right so maybe he knows that
being like there's no way I'm not
getting ass back like let me just tell
my side of the story and I think he
really thought I should do the same
thing she's in the same place yeah I
know but like Ariana doesn't need to
everyone Tom is out here burning his
whole life together like everyone else
is speaking for her let him act like an
animal and she just keeps posting things
on Instagram like being cute yeah
everyone at Team Ariana honestly less is
more I kind of like love what she's
doing this interview I I will never get
the brain cells and the hour and 20
minutes back it was so mind-numbingly
stupid and I love that Andy addressed it
and watch Happens Live is weirdly most
of the time not live anymore so if he
wants to address something like he has
to do it the next day and like it's kind
of awkward so I guess last night
happened to be an interview that was an
episode that was live and what he said
was
um he accused him of being the Jackal of
the day
um and accused him of apparently not
knowing what he was getting himself into
um on the highway Mandel does does stuff
podcast and he said now both Sandoval
and Howie are being dragged on social
media which is so true and he said Howie
you have to be careful before you take a
side Bravo fans are very passionate so
especially when you're going to take the
wrong side at the end of the interview
Margo first of all yeah we not have like
a publicist Margot like is there someone
to like be like I blame the daughter
like she knows the Optics and she let
her dad just so true Burn It To The
Ground at the end of the interview he's
like shaved Tom Sandoval's mustache
Margaret it was so stupid and kitschy
and at the end he was just like you know
to the audience like he's a guy he made
mistakes like it's not that bad like
it's okay if you see him out go to his
bar like really it was trying to be like
he's like riding for him Redemptive do
you think that like how he's like mad or
he's like happy because I'm sure he's
the most downloads he's ever gotten I
don't think Howie Mandela really cares
about like negative feedback he's a
lifelong comedian like you don't care
about [__] like that
um no I think he's overwhelmingly happy
with that his podcast that's pretty much
nobody knew about before is on
everybody's lips so true so you know
what what they say is bad press is no
press whatever they say no such thing as
bad publicity it's true yeah that's true
oh my God you guys I will never like I'm
mad at Howie Mandel like actually mad at
Howie Mandela for making money that you
just referred to him as a comedian
because when I think of Howie Mandel I
think of America's Got Talent when I
think of Howie Mandel I think of Deal or
No Deal
both not comedians no but those jobs go
to comedians like when you think of
Stevie why can't I remember his name
Steve Harvey excuse me what do you think
his talk show but he got a talk show
because he was a successful comedian I
guess Ellen comedian well yeah but that
I knew like every major like host is a
comedian is a comedian not so much these
days because it's like oh you have a
follower come Host this Kelly Clarkson
Drew Barrymore yeah that's true they're
like the jimmies the jimmies it's really
like to have a background in comedy you
can do whatever you want you can be an
actor sorry I'm about to take such a
left turn you go but did you hear about
James Corden and how like for his final
episode like One Direction might be
getting back together okay like I I
heard this fake ass conspiracy theory
yes but like there's a lot of like stuff
no there's a lot of good reasoning like
a lot of good reasoning Also if anyone
could do it it would be James Corden
okay but do you think that means like
One Direction four members or One
Direction five members four yeah I I
really don't well Zayn he like has
posted like two videos of him singing
and then night changes I think I just
want to say like I would prefer if it
was for the same I like literally hate
Zayn and I don't care like when he left
the band I was unaffected I'm like that
album was Firefox that was Midnight
Memories
a whole lot of history
um we could be the greatest team that
the world has ever seen you were met oh
you're done okay I'm sorry
um all right next up is the breakup news
of the century we don't need to go into
the details of the breakup but I did
think it was really interesting Taylor
Swift was seen out in New York City for
the first time since the Joe Alwyn
breakup news and also just like
we got a Paparazzi picture of Taylor and
we probably haven't gotten that in two
years no Taylor is only seeing if she
wants to be seen right so for me her
going out to dinner out on the town New
York City via corota which is a clear
it's like a celeb hospital
if you want to go see celebrities when
you come to New York go to Via crota
um
and getting Paparazzi that to me is a
confirmation of the breakup
okay that's her subliminal way of being
like yeah I just remembered that I had a
dream the night that this broke that um
Taylor and I like ran into each other
you're not okay I like became friends
and she was like telling me all about it
what did she say she was just like so
happy to be rid of him I kind of feel
like that might be her energy like she's
just like oh like finally yeah there's
also been reports coming out like people
trying to speculate at first it was said
you know sources say it's totally
amicable now people are saying he really
couldn't handle her Fame and he was
jealous that narrative makes a bit of
sense to me in terms of like it's too
obvious but that they were like in the
bubble in 2016 and then they went right
into the pandemic bubble and he's really
I mean this is her for this is her first
that's why never mind I would say this
is our first tour of that mess a couple
but reputation and he was able to handle
it then and that was really when she
would like emerged from like her dead
and it was like the snake whatever so
actually I don't buy it she is much more
famous and ubiquitously like well liked
right now well liked yeah but I don't
know I don't want to do that things
she's always been famous I'm sorry yeah
and it's all good things right now like
knock on wood you know like last time he
was like oh does this person like you're
scared to say the name Taylor Swift
because you don't know what kind of
reaction you're gonna get yeah whereas
now it's like she's beloved yeah I don't
think that's the reason I think it's far
too obvious I actually think like the
the kind of boring reasoning of like the
relationship just ran its course how is
that possible sorry I don't want to be
that person but how does like
when because it seemed like it was a
relationship where it was like they were
gonna get married like they were gonna
it wasn't a question it was just like
right silver
what you're saying if I date anyone for
six years it's run its course I don't
know I just it's a good question I
really don't know actually what that
means but I don't I'm just having a hard
time believing it's like a really and
like animus animus I don't think there's
any animosity yeah I don't think she
really does anything really with so much
animosity until she's pushed to the
point where she has to which is a good
segue into our next story so if you want
to say anything else about Taylor
Swift's breakup like who you want to see
her with now would be the time actually
it's on our next story forget it oh
um oh who I want to see her with uh I'm
really I would love for her to like date
like a star
when he was like nice and cute but like
he wasn't a star he was very like Indie
music festival like I want her like at
the Oscars with like uh but she doesn't
want red carpets with her man's so it
doesn't even matter who she dates
because we'll never see them together I
know and because I feel like she's
figured out that that's the recipe to
making her life work manageable
um so it won't even like matter so I
guess it doesn't even have to be maybe
it's just like a business member it's
probably better if it's somebody out of
the business because if that whole Fame
thing is true she dates like Ariana
Grande like met a real estate agent who
like from New York like and then like
married him like that would be [__]
wild to me it would be boring yeah yeah
and I'd be like why you yeah no it's
when you're that powerful as a woman
it's very hard it's like okay you could
date someone on your level
there are very few people let alone you
know hetero men that you have to like
that are single like it's I don't even
know who it would be yeah or you could
get somebody totally out of the business
that's just like boring for your fans
right or you did someone in the business
who's not as famous for you and then
there's the whole kind of thing they're
like Morgan Evans reading right but then
then it gets weird yeah 100 then it gets
[__] weird oh my God I had the
craziest dream about Kelsey ballerini
good bad bad I can't even say it it was
so crazy I'll tell you about it
afterwards like
it the tailors were in my dream and you
were probably there been like the Turks
and Caicos crew Ryan and I had we went
to a Kelsey ballerini concert she did
the crazy thing I can't even say it
because people are gonna think I'm so
psychotic yeah and like maybe don't
unwell yeah I'll tell you about it later
um yeah well anyway she seems to be
doing fine she's fine um and of course
if we're now hearing about it that means
she's probably had a few months to heal
I don't think this is a fresh breakup no
I don't think so at all um I'm just like
I don't really know how to listen to the
music anymore I know not to be that
person but like Shorty's like crazy like
love songs by like finally finding and
it's just like now it all feels like a
bit fraudulent no it doesn't feel
fraudulent because in the moment like
you feel what you feel and it's it's
okay to change your mind and change your
feelings maybe he broke up with her but
you know what you know who like deserves
a place in hell is like everyone of like
wants to news bro it's like can't wait
for the album oh like such good music
yeah like that's just like an annoying
thing people on the internet say yeah
it's like you're like oh because like
like on my Facebook which I never track
but like page six so I came up as like
one of the news articles whatever and
I'm like let me just like go like
is a Really Brave thing to do tomorrow
like yeah I would I don't know why I did
that I would quite literally never
um okay before we continue do you mind
if I just share a little tidbit about an
exciting new sponsor sure today's
episode is brought to you by single
drunk female on freeform Samantha Fink
started from the bottom and now she's
here somewhere in the middle-ish from
the executive producer of girls comes
the all new season of single drunk
female on freeform and on Hulu 549 days
sober and Counting things are looking up
for Sam this is the first birthday she's
looked forward to in Forever even if
she's spending her party hiding from
everyone in the closet she's living with
her overbearing mom still trying to hold
on to her not so dream job writing the
most important listicles on the internet
and she's knocking on her ex's door at
two in the morning which is never a good
look counselor I've never done that the
guardian called single drunk female a
Next Level fleabag it's refreshingly in
your face Raves refinery29 and BuzzFeed
calls star Sophia Black Dahlia a total
on-screen darling
and they dare you not to fall in love
with her your 20s can be wild and
complicated and being sober is even more
so but sometimes quitters win this show
is equal parts hilarious and
surprisingly emotional don't miss the
all-new season the season premiere is
actually tonight April 12th on freeform
and all the episodes are available the
next day on Hulu so again that's tonight
at 10 p.m on freeform and then all
episodes are available the next day on
Hulu check it out we watched last season
um and I'm so excited that the second
season is back I didn't realize you know
everything's happening so fast as well I
know oh my God where does the time go
it's really scary single drunk female
tonight on freeform 10 o'clock I like a
free form show did you watch Brooke
Shields pretty baby documentary no
because every single person that posted
about it was like this is like like a
service and I was like I'm not in the
mood to be disturbed that's fine I watch
it and this is an interesting tidbit so
Brook Shield says that the Blue Lagoon
director has reached out to her after
her bombshell documentary so Brook
Shield says um wait I need you to what'd
she say about it okay so the whole the
movie for anyone who hasn't watched
documentary including counselor we
weren't alive for it so we don't really
know but like Brooke Shields has been
famous since she was about nine yes and
she was this exquisite looking young
girl and she started modeling and it
very quickly went to [__] weird
levels and Dark Places yeah you know
when she was 11 she plays a prostitute
whose virginity gets sold and to this
man and she falls in love with this 30
year old man and they kiss and they
literally kiss there's a nude scene when
she's 11 in this like European art film
and then she does Blue Lagoon and that
really we've seen Blue Lagoon
um and she's 15 or 16 which is better
but still [__] weird because she's
naked
um and it was just this very disturbing
culture around Brook Shields and a lot
of it you know
it's like we don't the documentary was
like who are we blaming here right her
mother did not protect her her mother
was I saw a clip of like her on the Drew
Barrymore show like talking about her
mom her mom was like a crazy alcoholic
and her mom also grew up in that type of
you know culture where it was like you
use your body to make money and they she
was a single mom and it was just her and
Brooke and she used what she could to
get them a new house and a new car and
it was a very slippery slope yeah and of
course the industry for being [__]
weird in the culture yeah for being
obsessed with a girl and when she turned
18 like she couldn't get arrested nobody
wanted her like she went to college she
was like so famous by the time she
turned 18 and she never let it get to
her head like she just was this kind of
weird nerdy girl and she was this sex
symbol but everything she did was
sexualized and she was literally a
virgin and she went all through college
being a virgin and it actually came she
wrote a book
um like how to go to college and it was
like written for her and it was so
stupid but she did put in there because
she thought it was important like I'm a
virgin right and that's all anybody
wanted to talk about it was like virgin
virgin virgin virgin virgin virgin just
everyone probably made everyone more
even more obsessed with her sexually oh
my God so it was just it was such an
upsetting documentary and then by the
time she graduates College like she
can't get arrested because she's 21 now
like oh she's too old nobody cares
um and she ends up having like an
illustrious career and she's very
talented but so she went on the true and
Drew Barrymore was in the documentary as
one of like the testimonials because
she's a friend of Brooke and she also
she's a famous child star right so
during the actress's appearance on the
Drew Barrymore show Brooke Shields told
the host Drew Barrymore that Randall
kleiser who directed and produced the
1980s Blue Lagoon quote did send me a
call I saw his name on my phone and I
was like what do I do I let it go to
voicemail because I was like I don't
want to see what his tone is yeah and he
wants to chat I don't know I don't know
about what but I don't feel like
bringing all of it up again which I
totally respect I mean I mean what could
he say the movie and you know what we
saw the movie When We Were Young And I
think for a lot of people and that's
what they said in the documentary it was
very much like a Rite of Passage to see
this movie it's a coming-of-age story
learning about your body and it's
[__] weird it's [__] I didn't
realize she was 15. she was so young I'm
sorry
how is that not a child pornography it
is and so at the end of the movie she's
sitting down with her daughters and she
was talking about how like exciting it
is for her to be a mom now and like have
two daughters who are like so
independent and like have agency over
their bodies and and she never had that
and so she feels it's so important to do
that for her daughters and they were
talking about just like how weird it is
that all this stuff happened to her and
they were comparing it to euphoria
okay and they were like you know because
we're watching Euphoria which is like
really sexual about high schoolers but
they're 25. I would say yeah they're 25
and I was like that is so interesting
she like thought that was the craziest
thing and they're like Mom you know it's
literal child pornography and the
craziest thing was that like Brooke had
been shot nude photos when she was nine
like for like this artistic like book or
whatever
and they never were published then she
got really famous when she was like
maybe 15 or 16. the guy wanted to
publish them there was like full nude of
a nine-year-old and she her mom sued him
okay and they all went to court and it
was just horrible how they like
cross-examined her and they lost and
they published the photos he owned the
photos like that he should be arrested I
know but if it's art I think it's like a
blurred line isn't that [__] weird oh
my God that is actually disgusting yeah
and it was just like everything in life
with her book was so hard like she
wanted to get pregnant and she got
pregnant and she had a crazy postpartum
depression like couldn't even hold her
baby yeah and she finally wrote like a
real book about it like and it was all
about postpartum and how she was so
somebody finally got her in therapy in
like a change of life I think she went
on meds
and [__] Tom Cruise goes on the
[__] I don't know if it was
Oprah or GMA or some [__] and was like
because the book became this phenomena
for women they're like oh my God nobody
had spoken about postpartum they're like
I went through this too and like I felt
[__] crazy
and [__] Tom Cruise went on
this show being like always about Tom
Cruise yeah he was like it's really
irresponsible that she's telling women
to start taking medication and like you
know making them feel crazy that like
literally she was like I couldn't
believe Tom Cruise was coming for me I
she didn't even know him it was like
right but the book had become such a
like a thing being for women and he's
over here being a little [__] rat and
people [__] went after him and he had
to apologize it was good yeah it was
great it was great it was great but like
you're kidding you're kidding shut the
[__] up there's so much wrong with you
Tom Cruise I do one yeah right those in
Glass Houses Tom shut the [__] up the
call is coming from inside the house Tom
shut the [__] up you in your analogies
today oh am I saying a lot yeah like how
many times are you gonna say she
couldn't get arrested did I say that a
lot today yeah that kind of like my
favorite phrase what's your favorite
phrase oh
um honestly I do actually think my
favorite phrase is the call is coming
from inside the house yeah I'm so bad at
on the spot like phrases no on the
spotlight questions like even when you
were like about Taylor like what's the
price like I need to think well then you
really shouldn't go on podcasts that's
literally what the whole premise of a
podcast is yeah that's so true um I
don't know what my favorite phrase is
but I'll Circle back maybe that
oh great
um what do you think this guy wants to
talk to her about like apologize
um did she drag him at all in the thing
no they didn't say his name and honestly
like now I know his name you know he
should have just shut up so true
um I feel like probably apologize just
because in this day and age like yeah if
he were to not then that would be an
even big like you know what I mean yeah
I just like love Brooke Shields now like
I mean I've always loved her she like is
so like gorgeous she was so
extraordinary looking and so natural and
when you when you like see interviews of
her and these disgusting men and like
all they're like so you're a virgin huh
and they're just like asking really
creepy disgusting questions it's so
crazy that the world used to be that way
like people would watch us and not think
anything of it and be like oh let's go
to bed no I know I always see clips of
that even with like Taylor or like
Ariana Grande yeah and like people just
ask like random like just such a thing
invasive questions and I'm like in what
world and by the way wouldn't just be
men it would be everyone yeah yeah I
just love Brooke Shields like I'm
wishing her the best same is she like
married and like happy great so she was
married to Andre Agassi the tennis
player so so sorry you know what's so
weird is that I recently before this
even came out she came up because I
think she was at the Vanity Fair Oscar
party and I was like what's she been up
to so I went on a whole Deep dive on
Brook shield and I didn't know that she
was married and like that's a kind of an
iconic like yeah except he was like
really crazy and like abusive and he
literally she filmed you know that sort
of friends where she's in that she's in
that she plays an obsessed fan of Joey's
yeah so in one of the scenes she has to
lick his hand and Andre was there and
when she got offset he wasn't in the
dressing room he had stormed out ran
home and smashed every single one of his
Wimbledon U.S open all these trophies
because he was so embarrassed
people are not okay so it was like her
mom was very controlling and then she
like went to a controlling marriage with
Andreas she like is like normal I know
she ended up meeting someone who like
works in the industry I'm not sure I
forget where they met but he's not
famous he's like more of like a producer
and they're still married to this day
and they have two kids together and when
they were when they were telling the
story I didn't know her background and I
was really hoping I'm like please I hope
this is the guy like who's with the
father and they were all having family
dinner at the end of the documentary and
she seems like really stable and she
started like a business and a Blog and
I'm just so happy for her like I agree I
wish her the best like truly
um okay fourth story I'm gonna moving so
slow today sorry
Lily Reinhardt is a new man shut up yeah
and she's passionately kissing her new
bow Tick Tock star Jack Martin now I
read this article and Page Six is so
[__] shady and I chose it
because I'm like oh Margo do you know
Tick Tock star Jack Martin I've never
heard of tic tac star Jack Martin okay
and here they bury the lead a little bit
let me find the actual
Martin who stars in the new NBC show La
Brea like he's not a tick tock star he's
an actor why would they say tick tock
star in the headline
does he have a lot of followers I don't
know I just thought it was really
[__] weird
he's 24 she's 26 and they keep calling
him Tick Tock star Paparazzi caught them
making out outside LAX airport
um she was leaving and they were like
passionately saying goodbye to each
other and he looks he's very handsome
okay
um I don't know where she was going and
I don't know it's very exciting the
article says that he looks a lot like
Cole Sprouse he doesn't he's actually
much cute
he actually really does look like Cole
Sprouse wait he looks so familiar pull
up an actual photo of him if he think he
is he's so cute who do you think he is
no just like the face I feel like I've
seen him before he actually might be a
Tick-Tock star Jack Martin
images I'm sorry I'm being slow with the
iPad today I have a lot going on it's
okay oh it kind of does look familiar oh
my God he it does he's so cute wait let
me pull up he's like hot or cold what
does he do on Tick Tock no idea maybe I
don't know where I've seen him maybe
I've seen a show of him but I have seen
him before he has 800 000 Tick Tock
followers okay but I can tell you for
certain I have oh I've seen this guy
turn yeah yeah I've seen him he's a
Tic-Tac star he is a tick tock okay but
he's also an actor which is like I feel
like he's actually maybe more in a
Tick-Tock star than an actor actually
yeah I I wouldn't I would okay I was
wrong it happens all the time
um so she has a new man and like I don't
really care but there was a time where I
was upset I was thinking about after
that last night oh God Margo and I for
those who are new here we used to host
with Jackie and Ben
um a Riverdale after show the first one
two and maybe three seasons of Riverdale
were so so good I still culturally
impactful like everyone was watching
week to week it was so crazy we were
obsessed those guys got so famous like
and now they they're so famous but like
nobody cares nobody cares and I'm
curious this is the final season of the
show no one's watching anymore but like
gargoyles and ghouls it was Dungeons and
Dragons oh boy yeah where where do they
go from here counts like well I think 20
million followers yeah but also what I
will say is that
the show hasn't stopped them from taking
on other jobs like Camila Mendes is in
like a different Netflix movie like
every day that very problematic Netflix
movie did you ever see it which do
Revenge do Revenge with um Maya Hawk no
I didn't watch it it was extremely
anti-semitic I don't know if you know
that oh I didn't yeah oh we did a whole
episode on it I can't get into it it was
too harrowing okay
um so I feel like they like all take on
like so many different like projects
um so I feel like they'll just like
continue to do that like they must be
doing fine and maybe one of them will
take on a project that's like an Oscar
winning yeah but besides KJ APA is a dad
he's not really in which is it's always
like the star that doesn't like you know
what I mean like I feel like it's always
like in like these shows it's like this
like main character like Archie's
obviously like Archie and like Arch
Comics like whatever and he like I don't
really think has done like any other
projects besides Riverdale like very
much stays in his own thing all of them
except for Cami Mendez no Lily Reinhardt
does a bunch she like executive produces
a bunch of stuff oh really yeah um Cole
Sprouse whenever I think of Lily
Reinhardt maybe it's just like I don't
know if this is true I just feel like
she's like was complaining about
something she is always complaining
about like starting drama she was like
she was so true she was like spoke out
out of it against Kim at the Met Gala oh
yeah she's very like body positive but
like it's not very body positive to like
be negative about someone's body just
because they're like skinny right you
know 100 no she is always complaining
about something
um yeah so now I just kind of think of
her as like a whiny woman like I know
that she is by the way she's like always
whining about some [__] she's like also
always like on her story I mean I
unfollowed her actually because like I
couldn't on her soapbox yes on her
soapbox with like black background white
text like going off about something yeah
I find it annoying yeah um but I don't
know and like Madeline patch remember
when she was like a YouTuber yeah yeah I
thought that was interesting that was
like she thought it was smart Shay
Mitchell it was literally the Shay
Mitchell route Jackie like it's so tired
of hearing me talk about this but you
know what we haven't spoken about it
with you yeah what do you who do you
think is the most successful Pretty
Little Liar star
now
like dollars wise just everything
because if it's dollars wise it's
obviously Mitchell Fame because bass
like yes fame fame
Fame
because like Jamie shows like kind of in
the like she's digital she's like an
influencer yeah she's like revolve like
she's like revolved top tier yeah but
she like makes the money of a celebrity
as an influencer and her job is very
much influencing which is kind of Ideal
so would you say like Lucy Hale Lucy
Hale is like such a recognizable face
yeah I wouldn't say it's Trey Bellisario
and I wouldn't say it's Ashley Benson no
it could have been Ashley Benton yeah
but she's just like low-key yeah so I
would say it's between Lucy and Shay all
I'm saying I just like would love to
know like if someone like who's bored
and like wants to go do an interview on
the street like if you could just like
hold up both pictures and like just who
has the most recognizable recognition
that I'd love to know my whole point in
bringing this up is like I do find it I
will find out you're like pinning women
against women yeah that's literally all
I do here clearly you never watch a show
I don't support women
um I am just curious to see like how
they all shake out after this Riverdale
it was it's a very interesting case
study for me same because also I feel
like it was the first big show that like
truly like took over the world in a
really long time like from like Gossip
Girl era and now we've had so many of
those shows since like Outer Banks and
Euphoria but like Riverdale was first
yeah so this is the first one that's
ending yeah yeah so and it's ending on
like a flop it should have ended three
years ago well it should have been they
just should have never taken the show in
the direction that they did yeah that
too but yeah everything good must come
to an end yeah and the timing is so
important yeah it should have ended yeah
the fact that it's still on is just like
shocking it's the craziest thing to me
that's how I feel like I cannot believe
there are still people who get up and
watch a bachelor
same it's insane to me insane oh God she
sneezed on it it's true yeah all right
our fifth and final story before we get
into Deer toasters is a little bit more
Taylor Swift news because John Mayer is
like talking about it no he's not we're
at a concert I saw a clip of it on
social media and I wanted to make it a
story and I totally forgot so John Mayer
Reveals His new thoughts about his song
paper doll which is of course rumored to
be about Taylor Swift so John Mayer has
gained some gained some clarity on one
of his songs the singer Revisited his
2013 track paper doll during a concert
at the golden one Center in Sacramento
California as seen in a video
circulating on social media John mused
as he strummed the opening chords of his
guitar he said I wonder if people don't
like this song because it sounds a
little pissed off I don't really like
pissed off as a song he continued
there's something about it that's a
little [__]
the 45 year old tries quote not to give
bitchiness in his music he acknowledged
that it happened sometimes and called
out the song for what he described as
sarcastic [__] Vibes John added I guess
it is sort of a little bit bleh what so
take he's finally talking about it and I
have no idea what he's saying you have
to I don't understand I need a
translation what does this mean like and
by the way I don't even know like you
wrote the song and you just admitted is
it a little [__] and it's not good
like but I don't feel like it's a song
that people terribly dislike it was you
know when you compare so for anyone who
needs a little bit of background Taylor
when she was 19 dated John Mayer very
briefly and he did not treat her well he
was very much in his [__] boy era and
she was in her I'm new to this virginal
era marry me and she um wrote a song
called Dear John and it's a real
scathing
retelling of their time together I don't
really feel like she was like attacking
him I feel like it was like her song
wasn't caddy no it was just very it was
wonderful it was truthful and like it
was a story about like young innocence
and borderline trauma that's what it was
and years later literally nobody nobody
nobody John Mayer he released a song
called paper doll and the only real clue
that it was about Taylor is the line
because you're like 22 girls and one and
none of them know what they're running
from
um of course 22 is Taylor's thing that's
literally the only proof that's the only
proof
um and his song is a little mean because
it not only is it like 10 years later
why the [__] did you have to bring that
up yeah dude it is [__] it's like very
much you're not going to talk about the
substance of the relationship you're
just going to talk about like Digs at
her right but writing a song about
someone is writing a song and you know
when Taylor does it she has to be okay
with other people doing it honestly and
I'm sure that she is
I don't think she cared about paper doll
mostly because it wasn't this like big
hit right imagine like how many streams
do you think deardon has 500 million
yeah
yeah actually sorry let's look it up
speaking of I wanted to talk about the
rumor that
Taylor was shooting a music video in
Liverpool this past weekend and Taylor
Lautner was in it I just want to say
when you Google paper doll on Spotify
paper doll comes up and then Dear John
comes up right underneath I feel like
that makes sense how do you see how many
um
unless it's like in the top five uh oh
if you go to the album okay okay and you
might not be able to pull it up on your
phone of course not because why would
they make anything easy for a what album
was it it was Paradise Valley I think
paper doll oh it doesn't say yeah
whatever all I'm saying is like
competition wise Taylor's song is bigger
I actually could but if I got an answer
I couldn't share it with you oh I mean
you I could yeah but the audience know
and that's I'm limited in my power here
yeah I understand so Taylor
oh Swift there's like a rogue Paparazzi
picture going around of Her filming a
music video in Liverpool it's clearly
her she's like running out of she's
something with like the art in her hands
yeah and then there's another photo of
people claiming
um Taylor Lautner and Joey King and Joey
and people are thinking it's a speak now
music video but she's joking he wasn't
mean yeah
um I would love that and it is
believable especially because of all the
guys Taylor has dated I think not I
think I know the only person she's ever
really like wrote an extremely
complimentary nice song about and
totally took the blame for everything
that happened in their relationship is
like he came out looking great amazing
and also like I feel like they're
friends I feel like they're maybe not
friends but they're definitely on good
terms yeah and it would be great for him
it would be great for her I could
totally like it's there's so many crazy
tailor conspiracy theories out there and
I could definitely see this one being
true I just wanted to bring that up yeah
no I
I feel like I probably couldn't call
Taylor Lautner up Ben could they're like
really close yeah
um and I feel like Taylor Lautner might
not even say with Taylor with Taylor
Swift you have to be very tight-lipped I
feel like he wouldn't even say it by the
way I agree because he probably wants to
stay in that Circle yeah of course hello
yeah um okay those are the Fast Five
and you definitely needed to know them I
100 needed to know that but we have deer
toasters and we're also very excited
about what's about to happen because
deer toasters is brought to you by a
brand new sponsor that people are not
going to tell people are not gonna be
okay with okay they're not they're
they're not gonna be okay Margo tell me
skims Shut the [__] skins is the
solution oriented brand creating the
next generation of underwear loungewear
and shapewear for everybody so you guys
know Jackie and I are proud members of
The Big Titty Committee we have been uh
and for me especially like I have so
many back problems and I have the
biggest drugs ever and I've long been
searching for like many different bras
for different parts of my day you know
I'm out and about I need support I'm
inside I'm not one of these girls who
can't wear a bra I still need support
but I don't want that underwire digging
and I don't want skims that fits
everybody collection
um of underwear bras bralettes they're
lightweight they're form-fitting and
they are buttery soft they mold to your
body and they stretch to twice their
size when I first got the bra I'm like
Kim B oh yeah because it comes like it
looks really small and I'm like this is
Never Gonna fit my boobs and you know
how I found the bra that I'm obsessed
with is I was on Tick Tock and a girl
who she had just gotten um gastric
bypass surgery and she was like my boobs
are like getting like bigger and like a
little saggier and my back hurts and I'm
trying out bras and this is the best one
I found and it wasn't even sponsored I
immediately bought it it was glamzilla
she posted it and I fell in love I have
this bra in like three colors they make
such good bras for whatever you're
looking for if you're looking for like
underwire support their underwire
doesn't dig in the fits everybody
collection is I love the it fits
everybody's face if it's everybody they
have a great size inclusivity they make
great underwear bras
um they have different cuts and fits so
they have underwears they also have bras
they have dresses t-shirts bodysuits and
their sizing is extra extra small to 4X
it's offered in nine more colorways and
it's limited edition seasonal colors so
for me the racerback bralette
Chef's kisses so delicious it um I have
it in Black I have it in clay I have it
in a bunch of different colors and I
know Jackie really likes the scoop
bralette shout out honorable mention to
the scoop bralette it's fabulous so
believe the hype The Collection has over
90 000 five star reviews for a reason
skims fits everybody collection and
their more best-selling Essentials are
now available at skims.com plus get free
shipping on orders over 75 dollars
that's skims.com you won't regret it
dear toasters is also brought to you by
Jenny Kane have you ever been on the
Jenny Kane website you're in for a treat
your retreat think minimalist meets
luxury Jenny Kane items are classic
comfortable and California inspired from
the cotton or the cashmere knit sweater
you're obsessed with to the flowy summer
dress you never want to take off with
elevated everyday Basics and wardrobe
Essentials getting dressed is easier
than ever before when it comes to
investing in an outfit that'll last we
choose Jenny Kane for a limited time our
listeners are getting 15 off their
entire order go to Jenny kane.com and
use the code
toast to get 15 off so no matter the
season items from Jenny Kane are the it
item and you will get compliments and
you will be able to wear it season after
season I have so many items I've had
like a couple Jenny Kane cardigans for
like three years now they wear really
well they age really well because
they're made really well they're known
for their cotton staple sweaters so
they're best selling cotton cocoon
cardigan the Luxe cotton fisherman
sweater and the perfect off the summer
Chloe crew neck so these are pieces that
you can dress up or dress down all
season long Jenny King believes in the
one thing and that's the art of
simplicity so she focuses on Comfort
quality and Timeless design it's simple
it's stylish it's cozy and Chic have you
ever seen Jenny herself she's like a
fabulous girl she gets Nancy Myers
energy like you want to be that energy
the whole collection gives like
Nantucket yeah so if that's what you're
looking for like just trust Jenny no I
have a Jenny Kane cardigan that I got
like five years ago and I still wear it
like I know it's just a staple find your
Forever pieces at jennykane.com our
listeners are getting 15 off their first
order when you use code toast at
checkout that's 15 off your first order
j e n n I
k-a-y-n-e.com promo code toast the brand
go to for All Season Staples treat
yourself because you deserve it all
right Mark are you ready to change some
lives ready to change some lives all
right dear toasters is our weekly advice
segment every Wednesday you can submit
anything to deertoesters gmail.com
if we've read your query recently and
you want to update us [__] please
[__] update us I love an update we
don't have any updates today nobody
updates us they just take our advice and
run
but we got to nevertheless we persisted
all right hello Jackson Claude sorry
it's okay long time listener first time
writer I wanted to reach out and get
your opinion on a sticky situation that
occurred with my boyfriend I'm 24 and
I've been dating my boyfriend for around
six months now he's always expressed how
he wants to marry me and spend his life
with me about a month ago I got coveted
and I was stuck in my apartment for a
week quarantining during this time he
went out with his friends just like any
other Saturday and was out till 6am I
have this location and I noticed he was
somewhere I didn't recognize but
honestly I didn't think much of it
because he's never given me a reason to
think he would do anything to risk our
relationship but I just found out that
that night he went with one of his
friends to get a happy ending massage he
didn't think it was a big deal because
it was just a business transaction quote
and there were no feelings attached he
had gotten them before we were together
and he always claimed that he didn't
need to go anymore because he had me I
was Slash am extremely upset over this
because it feels like cheating having
someone else touch him like that and I
know he wouldn't be happy if I did it
also why would he have to go out to pay
money to do something like that the one
weekend I'm sick and can't can't see him
what would you do if you were me all
opinions and advice appreciated that's
so true like no no imagine she did that
imagine imagine she did that no this is
like in no way shape or form okay and I
feel like he's gonna it's like I'm sorry
you couldn't hold yours she's safe for
one [__] week do it yourself
masturbate yeah it's like my God I feel
like he's gonna try and guess like you
and to be yeah it's not cheating it's
like getting a massage like you go to
the nail salon like do not let this man
guess like you into saying that this is
normal yeah because it's not
do you think that this is deal breaker
is this something you have to have a
conversation like in like set boundaries
I'm like no I never I didn't even think
that people actually got Happy Endings
no I don't think that they did it that
they did that either but like maybe in
different parts of the country maybe I
don't like
it's yes it's a Jailbreaker for me
yeah it would be for me but I could also
see how it wouldn't be do you know what
I mean like but also if somebody I was
in a relationship with did that to me
it's it's it tells me more about you
than just the fact that you went and got
a happy ending exactly I would start
looking at this person differently like
that is prostitution like I'm sorry so I
would look at you differently for having
done that given the fact that like we
are in a relationship and you are
sexually active and you're not at this
desert where you just need someone to
jerk you off like I also just think that
if I was with someone I'm like obsessed
with them and like whatever and then I
find out that they did that like
immediate it
immediate act like I no longer like you
like I'm no longer I'm attracted to you
I no longer have feelings for you yeah
like I we are we're not I don't like you
I'm fully in agreement so I do think
this is a deal breaker I don't know if
people are gonna say that clutter that's
crazy like I I think this is absolutely
a deal breaker and also the way he's
handling it is like I tell you you said
you found out right right and I thought
when she was writing in at first at six
in the morning right I thought when she
was writing it at first she was like
gonna be mad that her boyfriend was like
out while she was like sick with Kobe
it's like girl I gotta grab like you can
go and I'm like oh this girl's crazy but
then I kept reading and I was like no
she's not I'm sorry I judged you I
judged you I did before I knew you I
think you are 100 Justified being upset
do not let him steamroll over you like
and honestly if you want to break up
with him you have my full support me too
but if you don't want to break up with
him and you want to like set a boundary
and see if he you know if you want to
give him another shot I'm okay with that
too I mean like by no means is this okay
but I would also just remember like this
person made a choice to do that like
what does that say about them just start
looking at him a little bit like through
a different lens yeah all right next up
dear Jackson Claude last week my husband
went on a work trip he doesn't travel
often and it was just him and a young
female co-worker traveling together so I
got a little nervous before the trip he
was paying special attention to his
appearance whitening his teeth applying
sunless tan
Etc a sunless tan yeah that's a little
Metro yeah during this trip he was oh no
sorry during the trip there was one
night I didn't hear from him and when I
mentioned it he apologized and said that
he thought I went to bed
here's the weird part on the way home he
missed his connection because him and
his co-worker were grabbing a drink and
quote lost track of time they rerouted
to another city but missed their last
flight home because they were there were
storms his co-worker had a family friend
that lives about 20 minutes from the
airport and they ended up staying with
her I said that made me uncomfortable
and he said they didn't have any options
because they wouldn't be reimbursed for
a hotel they slept in separate bedrooms
but something isn't sitting right with
me please help though somebody should
not be sitting right with you this is
[__] weird I mean honestly the latter
half maybe wouldn't have concerned me so
much like oh we grabbed a drink and
missed the flight and it made to stay at
her friend's house
is what did it for me what man sunless
stands for a work trip when I go on work
trips I literally look like a duty like
a rat like a rat no but like you can
understand like getting caught up in
like a workplace it's exciting if like
there's someone at work that you like
and like you go on a trip together it's
literally my dream no I know like I
definitely could see this being real
like this is definitely not a delusion
delusional also sunless tan I would like
to know yeah the whitening yeah I wanna
know a little bit more about the woman
like also because like if she's like
younger her and he's like older she like
oh like get away or is it like
she does she have a boyfriend like I
would like to know a little bit more
about it we need you to be like a little
bit like realistic like is your is your
man like a catch is this girl like
desperate like we need kind of
kind of mean like characteristics yes
but yeah I would say overall my advice
to you is that you are 100 but also like
she can't accuse him of anything without
like I think it's more to like keep your
eye out you need more concrete proof and
I think it's time to Snoop yeah like
he's given you more than enough reason
to Snoop yeah Jackie's very anti-snoop
so I can like get away with saying this
but like this is the time to Snoop
yeah she is anti-snute yeah she's like
Everyone's entitled to privacy and like
everybody's entitled to Pride she's
right but I think certain situations
require a snoop and this is it I mean
Ariana
only found out about Tom because she
snooped oh by the way yeah I meant to
ask that that's how she found out yeah
so it was like it had the news break so
a month ago they were at a um one of his
dumbass concerts for his band and his
phone like either fell while he was on
stage or she went through his phone on
stage and saw like sexual videos
FaceTime screenshots like really and she
told everyone and it came out almost
immediately maybe 24 hours later got it
um so with this girl you're not crazy I
think hashtag time to Snoop yep there's
never been a better time to start
snooping our third and final deer
toasters is kind of like making me
nauseous no hey Jackson Claude my
mother-in-law loves to cook and she's a
great cook she loves to host my husband
my brother-in-law his family yada yada
but there's a big problem though and
it's been going on far too long oh gosh
she's a finger licker ew and it's not
just like a little lick here and there
full-blown all fingers in her mouth she
sucks and it's not just limited to when
she's preparing and cooking the food she
also licks her fingers when we pass the
food around the table which is family
style so it gets on all the shared
serving utensils she even makes sucking
noise and noises when she licks her
fingers at the dinner table I'm so
grossed out by it to the point where I
completely lose my appetite it's not
only disgusting but it's completely
unsanitary my husband seems fairly
unbothered by it because of course he's
been exposed to this his entire life how
do I address this without offending her
and being pegged as a snobby
daughter-in-law or do I just get over it
and deal with it please help a not so
Finger Licking Good toaster
um you have to have your husband tell
say something to them no honestly she
can't say anything I don't think like I
think this is a situation like you just
have to live with but like never you
can't eat the food wait no I highly
disagree like I really think that the
husband can be like listen like I know
this is how we grew up but like other
people didn't it's kind of gross no it's
so obvious that it's gonna be coming
from his wife
but like fine maybe she'll like I don't
know have like be a little embarrassed
no like it's [__] rude like she's
cooking for everyone like you can't say
anything like you're in her house she's
like you'll just eat when you eat before
you get there
and push things around your plate like
you can I'm sorry you can't like I'm
with you this is disgusting and she
should be stopped but you know you have
to respect for your mother-in-law
she's the one hosting like I'm sorry is
there a father-in-law because can the
husband say something to the dad who can
then say something to the mom honestly I
feel like no because he would have been
mentioned he would have been mentioned
I'm sorry it's like to lick your fingers
this reminds me what an episode of Shahs
of Sunset that was probably one of my
favorite they're having like a
friendsgiving and Mercedes who's my
[__] Queen is making place for
everyone and you're their Persian it's
all very family style come here baby
June you know and she's making plates
for everyone and she's taken she serves
with her hands like she and everyone is
talking about how disgusting it is like
in their confessionals and she just
doesn't care she's serving everyone with
their hands oh string bean string bean
oh my God it is the funniest episode of
reality TV of all time and it reminds me
so much of this because like it is
really disgusting yeah of course but um
I'm sorry I don't think you can say
anything I think this is just something
you have to live with it's so rude if
you do say something and you're totally
justified but it's just it comes off
rude yeah I guess this woman should be
more self-aware and it really is [__]
disgusting and I'm not in any way
excusing her behavior but I want you to
navigate this and not get in trouble
yeah I don't think you can say anything
I think it'll be so obvious that it's
coming from you what like your husband
really [__] cares that his mom licks
her finger like moms gave birth to you
like so true it's not a big deal yeah
but now they're strangers there's not
strangers but non-blood relatives I
think is everyone talking about it like
is your brother-in-law like do you know
what I mean it seems like it's a her
thing um
yeah
um um I'm really wishing you the best
but that's a tough yeah you're toughie
you're just gonna have to like seriously
shut up and just keep keep your mouth
shut literally but also you know it
talks about the food is good she said
um you know I'm sorry you'll get
McDonald's on the way home like some
things are just not worth
not worth getting introducing foreign
bodies into your no not only that I also
don't think some conversations are not
worth having like I think you'll yeah
you might end up with more service
surest and and um more problems and
stress than than a solution here that's
just what I think thank you for
understanding being vulnerable in
writing and thank you to everyone who
was vulnerable and wrote in dear
toasters gmail.com uh if you submission
hasn't been read yet either it's boring
and there's nothing we can do about that
or it's simply too long so maybe rewrite
it just give us the need to know facts
we can't read see like listen the ones
we just read nice and quick yeah
um so just keep that in mind your
toaster gmail.com Margo it's been an
absolute pleasure thank you so much for
being here for having me if you're
looking for more Margo content you can
no longer listen to her podcast because
she quit I'm a quitter and
where can they follow you on Instagram
for tick tock same for tick tock also on
YouTube I downloaded lemonade I haven't
posted on there yet oh I downloaded it
too and then immediately deleted it I'm
too old for the show
um but yeah and then also listen to the
redheads yeah Marcus on the redheads
once a month thank you for being here
thank you for having me it's a pleasure
have a great day thank you guys so much
for listening to do this morning should
we deliver the Thousand stories you need
to know everybody on YouTube please
subscribe give this video thumbs up
talented we are have a great day we are
in studio again tomorrow with Tick Tock
star Remy Bader and we'll see you then
love ya bye